ờ
Tôi còn một phút để mà ngồi nói về tâm
sự
là thế nhưng mà chúng ta toàn tâm sự quá
cài thời gian này đúng ạ Giờ có mỗi hai
ôm Ok hai ông sẽ ngồi nghe tôi à
bạn xem máy video mà
Mấy ông nào muốn nghe tâm tôi tâm sự thì
kiểu gì cũng sẽ không bỏ lỡ đâu cứ nghĩ
thế
giờ thì à
Ờ thì đầu tiên thì biết ở tôi xin phép
hỏi mấy ông trước đã này
Ừ thế nào là Good Boy đổi mới ông trời
ông ấy tôi tôi mong mấy ông trả lời câu
này là tôi chưa Đã tôi tâm sự Cái dưới
trước nhưng mà rồi tôi sẽ trả lời câu ở
trên đối với ông thế nào là Good Boy đấy
Ừ ok
tiếp theo là tôi định đầu tiên tôi định
nói với cái
làm việc chuyên nghiệp
à à à
có cây cây để làm việc chuyên nghiệp tôi
thấy mà tôi cần phải nói mấy ông ngoài
việc hồi trước tôi từng nói qua mấy ông
gửi về việc là là văn hóa khi mà nghỉ
việc nghĩa là
từ khi anh nghỉ việc mình không thể nào
mà kiểu việc nó kiểu dạng là đang quá
nhiều Tự nhiên bình đúng phát nghỉ công
ty lúc đấy sẽ hiểu sẽ khốn đốn và sẽ
trách mình ạ người sau sẽ phải gánh hộ
cho tất cả những cái việc mình đang nằm
giỏ và vân cũng như là khi nghỉ việc thì
không nên nói xấu công ty cũ giống như
kiểu khi chia tay nữa thế
Nói chung là mình nên kiểu báo trước cho
họ rồi mọi thứ trong nhà để sao cho vợ
để mà đến khi nghỉ việc người ta vẫn có
ứng tượng tốt rồi mình về rất nhiều công
ty nó còn liên hệ lại công ty cũ mình
xem thế nào giống như ông mới nhắn tin
hỏi như cũ Xem ông ấy
thằng này đã làm những gì bạn chẳng hạn
đấy đấy thì
nói chung và chúng ta phải có văn hóa
nghỉ việc để biết đâu đấy về sau mình
Ngỡ Đâu mình đối tác với công ty cũ mà
Đấy cũng là cũng không nên là kiểu nhảy
sang công ty đối thủ cạnh tranh nhá
Không đây là lắm đấy à ờ ờ
anh nói chung là để về sau còn nhìn được
mặt nhau tại Khánh Như Thế Tôi nghĩ à
mình sống nên có tâm một tí ông ạ tiếp
theo thì cái vụ là làm việc chuyên
nghiệp thì
có nhiều bạn
trong theo như mình thấy thì chiều cao
đang không không thực sự chuyên nghiệp
lắm Tại sao không chơi nghiệp ở chỗ nào
không chưa nghiệp ở chỗ là các bạn nhắn
tin đang hơi
thảm hơi kiểu à đương nhiên là tôi vẫn
điển hình là các bạn nhắn tin cho tôi em
ạ Cũng không sao cả tôi còn người dễ dãi
người Ông nhắn tôi thế nào tôi cũng được
không quan trọng
nhưng mà khi mà các bạn đi làm ở môi
trường khác các bạn không phải là Cứ bực
bạn đâu Nhắn tin kiểu thoải mái được
không ạ Không cần giống như vì sau các
bạn phải học cả kỹ năng gửi mail cũng
phải có một ý kiến anh nữa không hiểu
mình mình phải nói chung là vị chuyên
nghiệp mà đúng không ạ Em có biết nhắn
tin nó chuyên nghiệp ở chỗ nào tôi thấy
được ra là nó không biết nói mấy ông
chưa Nhưng một tờ giấy không phải ai
nhắn tin cho nhiệt cái việc nhắn tin
chơi nghiệp này nó từ những cái rất đơn
giản nhất đó là nếu mà với ạ
Ừ nếu mà với làm việc ấy ông bắt buộc
phải có một kênh riêng chuyên để nhắn
tin làm điều đấy một kênh riêng này nói
chuyện kiểu chém gió các thứ thoải mái
không sao ví dụ là sử Messenger đối với
tôi nó không phải một cách nhắn tin chơi
nghiệp để làm việc khi mà bức khi làm
việc gì vì ai đó tôi sẽ sẽ kiểu bảo
người ta nhắn tin cho nên ra khác còn
Messenger rồi tôi không phải là nơi để
nhắn tin lại về công việc đối tôi có
điểm như thế
nếu không thể chuyển qua telegram Hoặc
là đi Con nói chung để tránh bị truy tin
nhắn của những người tin nhà Công việc
thì hôm nay để bị trôi không không bị
chụp không này bị trôi về những cái tin
nhắn khác không ạ Ai tiếp theo
Ý tao là mấy ông muốn làm phiền người ta
thì ông phải nhắn không không Rồi nó
định không ạ Đã từng Hồi trước của mình
hồi mình đi dậy học ở trường có dạng nửa
đêm sinh viên với các bạn nhắn tin hỏi
bài trắng ạ Lúc mà người ta nghỉ ngơi
thì lúc đấy là lúc ông rảnh không Ông
Hưng ơi ông ngồi học hành hạ ông ngồi
họp lúc này tập trung vẫn không có trọng
nhưng mà
Ừ nó kiểu à Tùy Đường thầy mới sẵn sàng
trả lời trong thời gian nghỉ ngơi có
người đấy còn không thì nhờ thầy sẽ
không thèm xem
ừ ừ
chợ hoa cà Xem 0 trả lời cái đấy được ra
không thể trách họ được bởi vì các bạn
nhắn không phải nằm trong giờ làm việc
của họ tự nhiên nhắn cho mình thì mình
thoải mái việc đấy Không sao cả Nhưng mà
nếu mà ông đi làm ở ở công ty Ông nhắn
như thế hoặc da thậm chí ông ăn những
cái nó còn tệ hơn là sử là kiểu nửa đêm
nó rồi Ông nhắn tin cho sếp Làm lại sim
mai nghỉ ạ
bộ phim sex gà đưa xe vào một cái khó là
kiểu Sếp không tìm được người thay thế
ông cấp cũng giả sử Nếu mà nếu là sử ông
cần phải lên công ty
để ông làm làm gì đó thì cho sắn à sẽ
không thích Được đấy còn nếu mà công
việc của ông còn ảnh hưởng vì ông làm
tại nhà được từ à anh em mình thì là tại
nhà cũng được ra nó không quan trọng
Ừ nhưng mà nhắn nửa đêm nó vào nội không
lên lắm trước khi có việc gì gấp
A gấp của ông thì mới tốt chứ nếu mà gấp
Nếu mà kiểu dạng là ông chẳng có gì gấp
rồi Nhắn tin tới sáng là ông không có
trường hợp mà tự nhiên nhắn tin để mà
xin mai đi chơi rồi ông ạ
Ừ nếu mà lời khuyên thật nhé và giờ sử
Mai ông tự nhiên có hẹn gì đó để đi chơi
ông đừng có niềm tin đừng có xin nhưng
phải nhắn tin thật lời khuyên của thầy
cũ của tôi đó là thầy không bao giờ trả
lời bất kỳ cái tin nhắn nào mà sinh viên
nhắn xin nghỉ
em không bao giờ luôn Nếu mà thực sự là
mình có có cái nhan mà xin nghỉ gan gì
khó như thế các bạn phải gọi điện
sự thật thôi các bạn Vinamilk cho lão
hoàng tử tế không nhắn tin
em nhắn tin nó sẽ chỉ là kiểu để trang
trí thôi chứ không phải là kiểu để nhắn
một cái gì quan trọng như tôi đã nói
Anh kênh Messenger là gì mà không nhắn
tin quan trọng nào nó
không ạ Nếu mà ông Có Dám Cả Gan xin
nghỉ để mai đi chơi rồi ạ đi chơi với
gái đi Ra Xứ Huế Thì ông phải Dám Cả Gan
gọi phải dám nói điều lấy nước nhờ nói
thì sẽ không không Mạnh mồm nói giờ nó
chéo đi tới rồi nói khéo mày không nghe
nhá Ừ
cho ví dụ là sửa Sếp tôi trả bạn ạ Alo
xe đã em
em à
Ừ hôm qua à Mai em lỡ đặt vé xem đi Nói
chung là đi chơi với mỗi bạn nữ em em
tìm hiểu bạn lâu rồi sẽ tạo điều kiện
cho em xin nghỉ ngày mai sau đó lúc em
sẽ làm bù vào thứ 7 chủ nhật sau A
à à
thực ra chỉ cần những cái câu đơn giản
đấy Chẳng cần phải hoa hải màu màu gì
nữa sẽ thoải mái thôi không vấn đề gì
rồi à
Ừ nhưng mà Đấy ông nên gọi vào ông nên
thành thật
Ê chảnh lươn tránh kiểu bảo nhà tôi cấp
vậy việc gấp của nhà thì làm việc gấp ở
nhà công việc đi chơi cứ nói hàng đi Giờ
trừ khi ông xin nghỉ quá nhiều rồi thì
ông ấy bắt đầu phải xem đó một cái do
khác nhưng mà chính vì như thế chính vì
những cái kia ông phải gọi điện trực
tiếp như thế khiến cho bản thân ông cũng
ngại khi mong dám xin cái gì được quá
nhiều có mặt ông thơ nỗi ông xin quá
nhiều cứ hứng lên là gọi như thế Thì ông
nên xem xét lại không ạ Họ sẽ phải xem
xét lại các vị trí của ông
Ừ
ok Vừa rồi tôi nói qua việc làm việc chứ
A lẫn cả con thêm vừa đi nữa
Ừ thôi phải nhấn mạnh mạnh Bởi vì bây
giờ tôi gặp vẫn rất nhiều Người Như Thế
Đó là những cách ngăn những kênh nhắn
tin chung của cả tập thể của công ty và
này không chat chit trong đấy Không nó
trí kiểu 2 người 3 người với nhau trong
một cái kênh mà tận 4 mấy người hai chục
người không đấy ạ
a cho dù ở kể cả ông ông Nghĩa là canh
đấy Cái chỉ nói chuyện hiểu vui thứ
nhưng mà thấy vui đấy phải là cho tất cả
mọi người cùng ai được như vậy hàng
chuyện riêng của hai người đặc biệt là
tôi thấy rất nhiều ông không trong kênh
màn tiếng cách làm việc cũng được bên
làm việc công việc bàn về công việc OK
nhưng mà vẫn phải tác riêng hai người
vào nhau kiểu địa hình hộp chữ ở trường
cũ thôi hộ kênh cảm kinh giảng viên đi
rồi các cô ấy hình như bị lười nhắn tin
riêng thì nhắn tin riêng mất tiền hay
sao ấy các cô giáo vụ có nhắn tin hỏng ở
kênh kênh kênh Trung đấy tác vào anh hôm
nay không đi làm à Hay hôm nay anh không
Anh hôm nay quên điểm là anh ở và vỡ làm
thay vì rồi áo kiểu Tìm tin nhắn riêng
tra riêng hạn với cô ấy Hình như kiểu
muốn cho mọi người biết được là các cô
ấy đang làm việc với ra nhắn trong cái
kênh dẫn 40 người cả bốn mươi đã xem cái
tin nhắn đấy và ông kia ở không xem
trong lúc buồn cười không mấy khó hiểu
tự nhiên thì phải mẹ tắt thông báo hai
mình thoát khỏi cái Tôi nói thật là tôi
từng thoát 23 kênh dẫn hết à anh bởi vì
mấy người Nhắn vào trong cái nhóm công
cộng cộng đồng đi Nó kiểu nhóm tập thể
kiểu nó tặng nhau lắm
Ừ
anh đây thêm một cái mấy ông cần tránh
với tôi con điểm tôi là như thế Nghe có
vẻ vẫn dậy rồi nhưng mà nhưng mà với tôi
con điểm ảnh như thế bởi vì chúng ra
kiểu sẽ đàng hoàng lịch sự hơn chục mang
kiểu dạng chuyên nghiệp hơn từ những cái
chi tiết nhỏ đi thôi Đúng ngoại với ông
sẽ thấy là từ những cái những cái tiểu
tiên gọi là tiểu tiết thì cũng đúng bởi
vì cái đấy nhỏ nó chẳng cái gì cả Không
ạ nhưng mà ở nó sẽ hình thành tính cách
của ông nếu mà ông để kỹ Mày cứ điều này
dần dần ông sẽ làm cô sự kiện chuyên
nghiệp cao trong ăn nhiều người cũng sẽ
kính trọng ông tôi tôi tự tin thì như
thế bởi vì à cho tôi đi những cái đấy
cho người khác cũng người ta không không
ai phàn nàn về cái việc mà tôi ở trong
một môi trường nó chiếu chuyên nghiệp
nha Không không ai phản chứ thỉnh thoảng
tôi
anh dậy muộn cho tôi trộm thức đêm không
dậy được Đúng rồi đấy ạ Lúc cái đấy thì
tôi đang thoải mái bản thân thôi à
a tiếp theo tôi xin phép trả lời cái câu
mà
vừa nãy tôi hỏi ông từ đầu Thế nào
là Good Boy
mùa đông thì bảo Good Boy không đi lầu
ngoài vẫn nhiều gần hết quên đi tiếng
nghèo good boy là em này đấy mấy ông cứ
tự nhận béo màu nude bôi nhưng mà cũng
không định nghĩa là rõ hơn bọt là cái gì
à
a good boy
a good boy trong bộ vest trắng đầy này
thì nhắn
kệ đầu tiên Ok Ui phép Xả đá phải Good
Boy này nếu mà dịch khô good là có tốt
không ạ boy là chàng trai không ạ
ờ ờ kéo dạng là chàng trai tốt nữa thì
thôi như thế đầu tiên thì tôi để nói sâu
hơn về cái từ tốt chàng trai rất là trả
khách sạn với mấy ông biết chàng trai ở
đây là gì rồi Cái gì quan tâm sau cái
tốt tôi không ạ cái tốt ở đây nó sẽ theo
ông Nghĩa Nà
nhất À
cái này nó hơi bị ở
mọi người tôi thì từ tốt đấy nó rất là
bị mông lung nó không nó không có một
cái gì ở Định nghĩa cụ thể cái Tư Tốt
này cả nó không thước đo là định nghĩa
nó là tốt cả giống như nhiều người tốt
người xấu cái lỗ ở thế nào người xấu mới
xấu sẽ làm hại người khác à người tốt là
người sẽ không làm hại người khác Chắc
thế chắc Thế ông ạ Mấy ông thực ạ rất
khó định nghĩa kể từ tốt với xấu ở ở
trong rất nhiều tình huống
sự là ông tốt với người này nhưng mà ông
không tốt người kia người kiệm sẽ lại
ghen tị rồi nghĩ là ông là người xấu vì
không không tốt với họ chẳng hạn thế
anh ra rất khó để mà trở thành một người
tốt nhưng mà rất dễ để phải người xấu
không ạ nhưng mà cái bài toán tốt xấu ở
đây chắc là cái từ Good Boy và thường ở
liên quan đến chuyện tình cảm thì những
hình good boy thì chắc là nó không nằm
trong việc tốt xấu ở đây đúng không ạ
nhưng tốt xấu ở trong chuyện tình cảm đó
là thế nào Tại sao lại Khái niệm và hút
bôi ạ Cả badboy đúng không ạ thì
thực ra cái ông ông có biết cái câu nào
liên quan đến Good Boy không ở trang
trại tình cảm thì đã thấy nói như nào
lên ngoan boy ở badboy hôm nào đấy biết
đâu ạ cho mấy bạn con gái thường hay
đăng nè đang thả thính ấy ý Anh thường
này đang giấu cái câu mà có nhà hàng
Good Boy và passport
ra để thôi á ạ
good boy cái gì là gút rồi Bad Boy
passport anh
chả nhớ nữa đây bác bad boy and Good Boy
Good Boy I'm fine đúng không
quân sư tiếng Anh hiểu đại khái kìa
Đó là kiểu hay xấu không tốt nếu là trai
ngoan thì không vui anh hiểu cái dịch
thôi như thế không ạ
Ờ Tại sao
thì tại sao thì
cô con gái Xong rồi béo thì toàn kêu là
có con gái con từ chối con trai tốt đúng
ạ và và kiểu toàn theo biết con sai xấu
thực tế là đấy em mấy ông đang quan điểm
cái tốt Nó bị sai nhưng thời gian nghĩ
là việc làm tại giống như mấy ông đang
bảo đấy mình tốt mà mình nhà chung thủy
với bạn đấy mà tại sao lại không có tình
cảm với mình đi
và đương nhiên à mày cái bạn mà lao đầu
vào mấy cái người con trai mà rõ ràng
xấu mà vẫn lao đầu vào mấy thằng con
trai đấy
à Xong rồi mấy ông Nghĩa là mấy ông tốt
hơn mấy thằng đấy thì à
Ừ thì mấy bạn ấy hãy bỏ qua đi mấy bạn
ơi mấy bạn à yêu sẽ vui và yêu không
dùng não mà ông không cần phải tán những
người như thế hoặc là bà ấy bạn đã yêu
Đúng kiểu không dùng não đây yêu một
cách điên cuồng mù quáng đấy thì tối ông
nên tránh những trường hợp đấy nếu mà
cũng có những trường hợp nữa
đó là
thằng kia nó cũng là trai tốt như là tốt
hơn ông cả về sự nghiệp cả về giữ nhiều
thứ khác vẫn là một hành nhà cũng gọi là
tâm lý hay mọi thứ rất nhiều cái hôn
Ừ ông ông ông được mỗi cái gọi là trái
tim vàng thằng kia cũng ở ra đến vàng
ông ngồi ông không có gì trong tay thì
đúng như ông chẳng phải người tốt Nói
thẳng như thế
bởi vì ông có thể Ông làm gì có quyền
lực để ông trở thành người xấu ông cùng
nó không đi ăn cưới ông ấy hay người xấu
thôi con đây ông rõ ràng ở ông không có
tiền để ông đi ăn chơi với nó không thời
gian thì không đi ăn chơi rồi không phải
cái bụng mặt thì làm thì để kiếm ăn thôi
chẳng hạn có thằng kia thì một là nó có
điều kiện ai nó cũng kiểu gì cũng được
kiếm được gì bằng gì cũng không biết nói
chúng nó kiếm được nó sẽ có rất nhiều
thứ để mà
à à Có nhiều thứ để mà kiểu nó trở thành
nó có thể hư được phép hư vì nó có tiền
để hư Ông chẳng có tiền để ông hư thì
ông và chả có tiền để mà kiểu ông ông
dẫn bài đi thôi ông phải có tiền không ạ
thằng kia có nhiều tiền thì nó dẫn bạn
kia đi đủ mọi thứ đủ mọi nơi và nó cũng
trải nghiệm đủ rồi nên anh à nó
em có nhiều thứ để mà giới thiệu để khoe
bạn kia còn bây giờ tôi thử nói mấy ông
ấy ông ấy Ông nhận với ông goods nhưng
mấy ông dẫn mấy bạn nữ đi chơi ở những
đâu hả chơi công viên à cho đỡ tốn tiền
thời sinh viên giản dị thế Ngoạ ơi mày
nếu bạn đấy mà đói thì mới ông ấy dẫn
mày đi ăn ở đâu ạ
anh hả ông già kể cả đi ăn Quán vỉa hè
luôn mấy ông biết được nhiều Quán vỉa hè
ngon không không ngon với mấy ông làm gì
có nhiều tiền để đi ăn đi chơi nhiều ha
Không nghẹn nghĩa là thực tế tôi không
nói ở đây thôi trên với ông Mười mấy ông
có nhiều hoàn cảnh Tôi cũng thế thôi
từng có tình yêu sinh viên tôi biết
nhưng mà ý rồi đó là
tệ do mấy ông đánh So sánh có nhiều tôi
tôi nói vụ này có Tại sao tự nhiên tại
nhắc cái vụ này bởi vì a có vậy sinh
viên ở có inbox tôi bảo về vụ này này là
tôi đành phải nói bởi vì đã số mấy ông ở
đây Sao mấy ông Toàn đã sinh viên chủ
yếu sinh viên chứ không phải là người đi
làm rồi Mỗi ngày tôi chứng tỏ đấy thì
cũng sự thật đó là anh hiểu mấy ông đúng
là không vui mình không thể ngắn thật
bởi Nếu không có điều kiện Ừ thì mấy ông
nên cắm đầu vào để mới đẹp mà gọi là có
điều kiện thêm một tí
A và thực ra vẫn có thể là gặp các bạn
nữ mà gọi là có tình yêu tuổi học trò Mà
kiểu dạng vẫn thiếu thốn một tí nhưng mà
nó trong sáng được không sao Nhưng thực
sự thì mấy ông nên lá có điều kiện trước
đã trước khi hiểu
tình nên mới cái bạn nữ h hiểu đi chơi
hẹn hò các hư Hử
anh bởi vì ít bạn ở chấp nhận mình lắm
Bởi vì về cơ bản thì con gái vẫn mong
cái kiểu tủ an toàn và gì nhỉ tui có vài
bạn mạnh mẽ thì mời bạn ấy cho thể tự
chu cấp ơi còn không tùy
boy à
à à
xe máy xúc và tôi nói qua mấy cái đấy
thôi chủ đề này một chủ đề cũng khá nhị
ca nhưng mà
Ừ tôi chỉ muốn nói đó là Cậu dặn mà
người một có trái tim vàng người ta mà
không thể hiện được ra 10 điều gì thì
thì không không ai tin tưởng được mấy
ông mấy ông Chả tin được mấy ông đâu
hoặc cả Hồi trước có câu nói đó là
đưa ra xử Vì sao ông có con gái ông có
muốn cho con cái ông hẹn hò anh một đứa
như ông bây giờ không
Ừ ông trả lời câu ví
Ừ ông chưa thiếu nhìn thấy được tương
lai hay sáng xúc ở Tưởng đã lành nhưng
mà nếu ở ra xử thằng ấy đang bảo chẳng
có gì trong tay cả sau muốn than Nó như
vật chất hơn hay nói chung nhà có thể
tạo điều kiện tốt hơn cho con gái mình
không suy nghĩ gì nào đấy lúc rồi em sẽ
biết không phải làm gì
suốt tế với ông chưa gì nữa khẳng định
tại thế Ờ tiếp theo ý
a tiếp theo mình xin phép trả lời mấy
câu hỏi về đầu tiên à câu này mình sẽ tí
thì mình sẽ chữa này có mày câu bạn ấy
bảo là
em lấy à
những
bài thơ
cô bạn lớp trưởng rồi nhá Đấy với nhau
nó chưa có trường đấy à
à à đầu tiên thì nó Tiên thì có bạn bảo
lấy cái in cái giá trị ngẫu nhiên của i5
như thế nào nó sẽ chuyện với ông
có thể thao lúc đầu rồi không biết là
bản sẽ cái thằng i5 nói như này mà nó sẽ
kế thừa cái này nhà các bạn thể ấn Click
vào để xem được thực sự hay có những hàm
gì ra rất nhiều cái đây bạn chẳng hiểu
nó sinh ra nhưng mà ông mời ông thực ra
chỉ cần gì tên là ha là mấy ông sẽ hình
dung được nó là cái gì và trong ngày kéo
xuống dưới này thì nó sẽ có cái khái
niệm kiểu ghét ra Đun em ạ Ra lấy được
là donkey này nurimaru rồi lấy ngẫu
nhiên khi nào đó hoặc là lấy cũng nhân
và lưu cho ra mấy ông thích thì mình bản
chất là nó gọi đến hàng này số gọi đến
hay mày không ạ đúng không đấy mà được
vụ tai nạn dễ hiểu màn không ạ ạ
ờ ờ
xe đẩy nghĩa là tôi ngoài Tao chỉ mày
ông về cái á
anh alo gì
ở ngoài tôi chỉ cho mấy ông về việc và
trả lời một câu hỏi thôi vô chỉ ở mấy
ông khách thì hôm ấy ông thể về sau kiểu
có thể tự tự tự mình mò có rất nhiều
cách để tự mình mò một lên tra tài liệu
hay là lên hẳn Nói chung những cái trang
tài liệu tra ai vào Thằng Cốt nó để xem
như thế không sao cả
a tiếp theo ở
Ừ cái này cái gì nhỉ
em à mỗi cái này là cái những cái Xem
FIFA thì có một sự thực tế đó là tôi vẫn
còn theo dõi cái gì khi phóng viên thật
Chị Thơ Tố không dùng ghép code mày ông
có thể theo dõi kênh này để mà xem được
rất nhiều mẹo về vé code các thứ thứ
tôi xem không phải để tôi về sau với
định làm vé cốt đâu nhé Còn tôi xem có
thờ để mà kiểu nói chung Tôi là dân công
nghệ thì có những cái gì hay ho những gì
mới mẻ với công nghệ tôi vẫn thường anh
xem để mà biết đâu nó sẽ còn cung cấp
cho mình thêm nhiều ý tưởng nữa ngọn rất
nhiều cái rồi Chỉ cần nhìn qua ai đủ
biết được Và khi viết một cái tài liệu
thì mình nên phải viết như nào Vân Đấy
là một cái này
anh nói chung à bà lẫn cả là pesto mày
không có kênh Cai vãi nhưng ở Nga phải
sẽ tạm cái đối thủ à
là hay
khi có sự thật Mấy ông không biết mày
Ông thử lên Vài vai tôi rồi còn cái gì
để cảm không nhỉ xem nhé
chắc không đi đâu
Ừ ừ chắc không thì ạ à khi nếu mà giờ sử
mà bây giờ có một cái tình huống này là
sử là tôi có 1 file này tôi cần chia sẻ
cho mấy ông đúng không ạ tôi cần là
nhưng mà cái file này Đây là file trên
dri của tôi thì tôi thấy ấn phe thì có
hình sẽ lực lập tức trong người ông được
đúng hạn đúng không ngày ok nha Nhưng mà
nếu mà giả sử cái pha này không phải là
vai của tôi pha này file nằm trong xe
đẩy tôi không dám bấm rồi Biết đâu cái
trong anh đi cả để tôi thử kéo sang
miếng khác xem cái gì bị cảm à
em ở nhà lúc này tôi lỡ mở cái vài cái
thư mục gì đó ở trên telegram họ sẽ lưu
lại để kết thúc một nó hơi bị cảm một tí
không không sao không làm Sao tôi mở tài
khoản khác cái ra xử là bởi cả những cái
hoa sen with me thế này nóng lạnh thì
mấy ông tùy từng file tông sẽ có chuột
phải vào để mà sevp như thế này không ạ
tù file nhé Có những file không cho phép
ông kiểu xe kiểu như thế này Thế ông làm
thế nào Ví dụ giờ sự nói chung có một
Vaio không được phép chia sẻ đâu thì ông
sẽ làm như nào còn trông sẽ làm như nào
ạ
ông ông sẽ có cái khái niệm là ông tạo
bản sao made copy như này ông tạo một
bản sao sau đó sau đó thì ông sẽ tập
trung tập trung sau đó thì ông sẽ và lại
bên dai của mình để mà được chuột phải
vào cái thằng đấy gì mà tạo cái link để
Mới chia sẻ không ạ Đấy nhưng mà lấy là
lại còn thêm trường hợp Nêu các giả sự
là cái tạo bản sao này báo lại chỉ chỉ
có 1 file mới đạt được vào xa nhá ông có
rất nhiều file như này ông cần được chia
sẻ toàn bộ này có gặt liên hoàn thư mục
Đúng không Nó gì có nút đảo Hoàng Sa ở
đây cho ông ngoạn cho em mấy ông thấy
đất nước sẽ không được của bọn Thế mày
Ông cần làm nha Thường mấy ông còn chơi
trò là mấy cũng phải mất công phải nó về
sau đó thì ông lại phải đẩy lên phải up
lên Drive của ông rồi Ông ấn nút chia sẻ
thế rất là mệt mất công nữa ông ạ Thế
nên là bây giờ Hồi đấy tôi đã có một cái
cách này đó là mình cầm tạo bản sao
nhanh toàn bộ tất cả file này Và thậm
chí còn không mục vào trong tí nữa không
gọi thì mình sẽ có thể tích là copy
folder
Tải Google Drive thế này
Em mở cái gì ý ngay
ừ ừ
chị sẽ ngày da xịn xịn luôn à
À mà anh này nói chung với anh này làm
lớp trình để mà kiểu nói chung là cái dễ
dùng lắm ông Trịnh ấy cũng chọn chọn
xong rồi ông đặt tên thư mục đấy Xong
rồi nó sẽ copy toàn bộ những cái thử
liên quan trong chung mục đấy những cái
file mà ông muốn vào cái thư mục của mấy
ông ông cần đấy nó copy được nó tạo bản
sao đâu cho ấy sau đó thì ông đứa nào
Ông đợi nó chạy xong thông báo thành
công trong là ông chị cửa cần cho phải
để tạo thôi tôi dùng cái tiện ích này để
từ lâu rồi dùng tiện ích này để mà copy
tám mấy mấy nghìn cái file ở trong một
cái thư mục cơ bởi vì à Chữ ông ngồi thủ
công cho phải tao làm sao thân cái đó
không ai ăn cái cả Không ạ Đây cái ngày
mà tôi muốn chia sẻ với ông một vì à
Mình ở Dân công nghệ mình phải cái gì
vậy ạ
em phải biết qua đúng ạ mình thay thay
vì mình có thể tự làm mình sẽ trao
Google như này xem mà đã có ai từng làm
mới chưa không ạ Nếu mà nếu mà có người
làm rồi thì mình sẽ dùng ạ thấy rất là
một trong những cái mà kiểu dân công
nghệ mình tiện hư dân không phải dân
công nghệ thì họ sẽ sẽ phải tạm phải tải
thủ công về đấy
từ
80k file bị cái đấy là tài liệu tài liệu
hồi đấy tài liệu giảng dạy ở trường tôi
Nó rất nhiều file kiểu phải nhắn cho
khoai Tech cái gì Bài tập nhiều lắm
Trẻ nhỏ dưới nhiều thư mục thế nên là
anh ra là thành ra là kiểu nó và lẫn cả
trong đấy có cốt nữa thành ra nó kiểu
lắp nhắn mỗi thứ một tí mày không hiểu
này nói chung mà chắc là mấy ông không
bỏ rơi trường hợp nó nhiều loãng như thế
đâu nhưng mà sẽ có trường hợp và tầm
chục file thôi ông lười rồi thì ông chỉ
muốn cái tiện ích đấy Xong rồi nó sẽ tự
động copy hợp âm thế xong ngoạn Tại sao
mất công thế ngoài ra 2
Bây giờ mình sẽ mình sẽ tạm để môi cho
mấy ông về cái á cậu SG phức tạp và như
thế nào
anh ở đây dùng phức tạp bởi vì ah hôm
trước là có một bài toán của một bạn
thôi xin phép mở this post lên tý nhé Ở
có một bạn inbox riêng của tôi để mà nhờ
tôi chữa một câu esquire cũng có cả đó
của mình A có cả nào tới bây đây à
anh đợi tôi tí
về à
như thế này ở trong nhà Lava thì sẽ làm
như nào
Bye bye
đã có 33
mình nó sẽ khá phức tạp
khi họ sẽ kiểu à Nó sắp quay ở các xưởng
nhé
ở đầu tiên tôi cư import nó vào thì
inbox cái này lại nha có sẵn varya hư
rồi thì thằng nhà thằng hai đít này tôi
ngỡ như là nó đỡ tí này
thì phải nhưng mà tôi không tội chẳng
tôi chưa dùng để post hoài vậy
cho tôi sẽ tạo một cái thứ cài đặt vào
bầy mới nhá mình sẽ là ở
a crash
dùng Trung Hải được Chắc không sao đâu
mình sẽ có Lost thử xem xem bác được
không
bàn không
nói này liên quan đến ra một khối ngoại
tại xóa khóa lại đi nè
thì tại sao khoa ngoại đĩa
và cô đặc
anh ở đây tôi cho mấy ông xe mà ở
anh ở đây bài toán thực ra nó phá đơn
giản Nó là kiểu có Toàn có tất cả sản
phẩm không ạ Có bảng khuyến mãi rồi đúng
không ạ khuyến mãi rồi nó có khoảng thời
gian là từ bao nhiêu bao nhiêu khuyến
mãi được bao nhiêu Lô ra cái bàn phím
mãi là bạn đang làm không hẳn là không
hoàn tốt lắm nhưng mà nói chung ở đại
khái như thế tiếp tiếp theo là sản phẩm
nào được khuyên loại khuyến mãi nào
em và bạn ấy đang bảo là có trường hợp
là nhỡ đâu một sản phẩm Nói chung tập 3
cái khuyến mãi cùng cùng một khoảng thời
gian như này thì mình sẽ phải lấy cái
Khuyến mãi lớn nhất của cái sản phẩm đấy
mà em bé uống hình dung bài toán không
đó là mình có khuyến mãi đúng không Và
mình có sản phẩm đúng không ạ Bây giờ
mình cần lấy ra tất cả sản phẩm kèm theo
khuyến mãi nếu có nếu có nhé đầu tiên
thì cái việc lấy tất cả sản phẩm với nó
chỉ đơn giản là sẽ rất sao form
cô đó đúng không ạ là lấy tất cả sản
phẩm mới không ạ nhưng mà bây giờ mình
cần lấy lấy ra toàn bộ khuyến mãi cao
nhất của sản phẩm nếu có hiển thị ra ông
ạ thì bản chất là mình sẽ đầu tiên thì
bây giờ chạy chạy nói đấy đấy tới tất cả
sản phẩm và ok rồi mình sẽ để tạm thời
đã tiếp theo mình sẽ lấy ra tất cả sau
tất cả gọi là
khi cây khuyến mãi cao nhất thì sẽ làm
mát mà nó gọi thì mình sẽ có select mắc
đây mắc cái gì đây nó sẽ có cột a và cột
à ít cows ai đây Wide
nếu mà làm như thế này thì chỉ lấy ra
cái
a discount Price lớn nhất Đông lớn nhất
thôi cũng không phải biết treo cái sản
phẩm nào hay không Nếu mà muốn cụ thể
theo từng sản phẩm thì mình sẽ phải nối
xanh bạn discount code này sau đó thì
mình sẽ lấy Goodbye theo peroxide Tại
sao phải hút bao nhiêu Cola ra đi vì với
từng sản phẩm thì có mã đi Cao khác nhau
thì mình cầm lấy thằng lớn nhất của từng
sản phẩm đấy thì đây sẽ cầm cả rất đi
này
vì vậy là như này sau đó mình có đi cao
nha cho mình sẽ cho phẳng với thằng
discount codes ạ
thì tại sao mình có thể dùng injo ở đây
bởi vì à Bởi vì các bạn Mình chỉ quan
tâm mấy thằng nick ireport nào có thành
phố nào có đi Cao mình lấy ra thôi ông ạ
Có có trường hợp với đi cao nó có nhưng
mà vội chẳng có mua đắp nào dùng cái đít
cao đấy cả thì mình không cần không ạ
ngon discounts
anh trầm ID bằng
skout.com sukhawadee ngay cả hạn đúng
không
Ừ nếu súng ngắm nhìn rõ nha ô nhiễm mà
tôi chạy này cho tôi lúc bye tôi đó cái
đi rằng ạ miếng sẽ xảy ra nó sẽ ra là
thằng này không ạ Có cái đi cao lớn nhất
ở như thế này phải có đi cao lớn nhất
những ai phải đi xklđ nếu là Nga chọn
rồi ông ạ Tôi sẽ copy cái này sang bên
này như thế này có bản chất À cái này
mình cầm ở đây là gì mình cần Chỉ thị
toàn bộ thông tin sản phẩm này kèm theo
mã this cao lớn nhất Hoặc nếu có dùng từ
nếu có tất cả có sản phẩm không có thì
mình sẽ đây mình sử dụng navdroyd với
các bạn kia như này nghĩa là mình sẽ lấy
toàn bộ về bên trái rồi do được với
thằng ở bên phải thì gọi không ạ
sẽ như này
à Xong rồi mình sẽ đặt tên cả cái bàn
này là ví dụ là p thôi chẳng B thằn lằn
như thế này on d.vu đó phải đi
ảnh bằng qua đất chấm
Mai đi cũng được
mạng thu đắp của mình còn lại đi 2 phút
nữa đi à Hãy để bố đây điểm mà hơi bị
loạn
phố Đắt hay đi này Ok này tiếp theo đó
là thức à mình không nên dùng sẽ thích
sao đây lắm Mình sẽ cô đắp chấm như thế
này phải rồi à
ở đây ở đây tôi sẽ chỉ lấy đê chậm á
mình sẽ lấy cột này mình sẽ đặt tên còn
này là mắc discard ạ
và mình sẽ lấy con mai ở đây thế này à
nhà mình có hai cô
a slack
con chó nó cũng sẽ thấy là có sản phẩm
thì có đít cao có sản phẩm đi không đúng
ạ Toàn bộ câu trên phần anh như thế này
nó thức à nó không dài lắm lúc bọn nó
không dài lắm nhưng nó sẽ như này nhưng
mà bây giờ Ok anh ngồi chuyện với đủ rồi
Thế bây giờ anh phải ra được có chút vấn
với anh làm thế nào rồi mà
viết lario về vụ này không ạ Tôi sẽ gửi
chỉ mấy ông nhá
Ừ tôi sẽ mở test controller lên để mà
Mình sẽ vứt vào trong test nhé á
trước không Tạm xóa cái này nha
ờ ờ
rất nhiều cách để mà Mấy ông thể viết
câu truy vấn này hồi hồi mà tôi không
biết Tôi không biết đấy thôi thể chơi
trò này PB này do như này thế là xong
rất ngắn gọn nhé theo toàn bộ mọi thứ
vào trong như thế này đấy như này
ở đâu rồi bây selec Grow bị đúng select
xong rồi á db2 chấm do Nga nghe xong
thì nó sẽ dầu xà lách hộ Minh tôi Peter
giá trị của toàn bộ và nay cái này là nó
sẽ không Biến toàn bộ giá trị mình xử lý
nó thành đối tượng mà biến hình mạc bình
thường thôi chấm yêu hồi làm TP à
đã test này nằm ở đâu đấy
đã test nhà ngoại hình như thế
à à
Anh đang mở gì không
xe tải nó sẽ trả về dữ liệu nhà cho mấy
ông đó ngoại nhưng mà chúng ta ở đây
không làm thế chúng ta phải làm thì cậu
mua đồ đối tượng các thứ thứ thì mình sẽ
giải quyết các bài toán ở đây như thế
nào Tôi đây sẽ tạm xóa là mày đi này
Ừ mình đây mình sẽ cầm là ở đấy thì
thường tôi làm gì nó sẽ là như này mấy
ông thấy vừa rồi tôi ở đây rồi đã chia
cả hai thằng một thằng bạn mới không ạ
một cái bàn rồi sau đó thì mình sẽ dùng
cái bàn phu Đắc thể nối với cái thằng
này không ạ Ừ thì đây mình sẽ cầm là nó
sẽ hơi phức tạp một tí như thế này rồi
cho bé uống xe đây mình sẽ cần tạo ra
xã hội bị mất công của Tí tôi sẽ tạo
nhanh Romeo nhé Có thằng nào nó đang ít
nhỉ Có thằng này đi mình sẽ copy hàng
ngày tạo thành tên là post code đi thì
có một thằng là khổ đắng này
ờ ờ thấy bồ bạn ấy nghe lại là không có
chữ S không ạ Mình sẽ đặt lắp nick à
tích hợp tích cực nha
Ừ Ừ chắc là như thế này tiếp theo mình
sẽ có là this k a
anh lái xe discounts à à
a tiếp theo nữa mình sẽ có là code this
cao không ạ
cao thì ỉa
Ê
hồi trước thì tôi đọc thì hình như thằng
này nó là find trung gian nữa thằng hai
thằng thì mình là mình sẽ không kể
thường ấy mua đồ mà mình sẽ kế thừa
thằng tay vợt cơ nhưng mà tôi thấy ở
thời cả bây giờ phức tạp và Mình tách
riêng nó thoại tại mua đồ bình thường
này không sao là ngồi tôi cứ mò mãi vụ
virus khác làm nhà
ở đầu tiên thì mình cần đấy Mình cần lấy
cái thằng Minh lại cần lấy hàng dưới đây
trước nhé mình cầm tạo thằng ấy trước
thì sẽ là mình đây mình sẽ có là một cái
thê bồ thứ hai mình đặt tên mình tên là
gì tôi không ạ Rồi bảo nó tên đê Thật ra
ông là tên Đây là thấy bố hay được này
sau đó thì mình sẽ có là đi cao ở đây
không ạ thì discounts
ở tại giỏi quá đi Ở đây xong rồi mình sẽ
gọi đến Hằng à
nhà mình cần tôi thường là sẽ lấy trước
đấy chứ không có mẹ roi Dũng đã từ từ
trước mình sẽ là xe khách ở đây mình cần
hai cái sẽ lách một cả là snack kiểu
bình thường một cái snack ở đây là snack
có thêm hàm em mình sẽ phải thêm tự do
Đây để món salad được khéo hàm mình sẽ
là salad kiểu bình thường Thì sẽ là
ừ ừ
I
thought ID này à thế này sau đó thì mình
có
ở đây ông có thể dùng xe necro ngay
copy Cola này và
lo tất cả Thuận không không tắt thiệp xử
lý gì đây cũng mấy ông cả
sau đó thì ông sẽ do hoài không ạ cho
đây mình sẽ có discount
codes ạ
- support
à à
Có ai đi và discount
không vào nó bôi gì đấy thế
này
tiếp theo và
đấy on dựa trên cái gì bà ru bye em ạ
goodbye I
ở đó phải đi
thế
này và mình sẽ không có mình mình sẽ
không có kiểu à
a z ghét dữ liệu cái này vội Mình không
dùng cách nói cho mình tạo câu truy vấn
nha thôi sau đó Thì bây giờ mình có
thông tin của cái thành phố lắp Mình sẽ
do I với thằng này mình sẽ data nghe
chẳng bằng cô lắm
barie này
ạ sau đó thì mình có led Voice
hay lắm chị ạ Nhưng mình cần đặt tên nó
về thằng này theo kiểu ngày thì mình sẽ
có là
ờ ờ Tôi thường này làm thường phải ghi
ngay nhé em
truy vấn này không đúng lắm cái này tôi
thường làm là sắp cưới mà
ừ ừ
Mẹ
Maria đẹp cho
a a khóc cho rồi
Đã lâu rồi không viết thì cậu như này
anh có lỗi cho cậu
a cho phe Android
người thứ tôi đang định bảo đây mình sẽ
dùng hắn trôi sắp cho rồi do bình thường
à
ở
nhà mình mới có toàn bộ câu truy vấn ở
đây sau đó thì cách đặt tên của mình
phải ở đây sẽ là cái thứ 2 tức là mình
sẽ đặt tên nó nghĩa là gì sau đó mình
giữa kháng sinh nhưng ai
EZ này à ờ ờ
ạ sau đó thì mình sẽ có à
đôla dọn được thì mình là tên rồi sau đó
thì mình sẽ choi dựa trên cái cột Duy
Ơ con này sẽ có bass ấm pin sẽ có bắt
chước ở đây thôi B chuẩn caller ID
E bằng gì bằng code
à à
gì chấm vô hay đi như này không ạ sau đó
thì mình sẽ back 2 cái này không ạ mình
để xe lách tôi thương để sẽ lấy ở trên
Nhưng mà thời ra thằng này mà đăng sinh
ra câu truy vấn hộ mình rồi nên anh em
mình đi kiểu gì được forick chấm sao này
A và tiếp theo mình sẽ lex-do Axelo thêm
cả
a b chấm
à à
a
t.me tích cao đúng
Ừ kệ như này
Ừ nó sau đó thì ông Chỉ việc lấy ghét
lấy tất cả
đôla data mình xem nhé
chưa chấm phẩy vậy à
cho nó đúng thì ở đây cũng đi một nhược
điểm đó là sao bởi vì à riêng cãi salad
này khi ông ghi Dạo này nó hơi bị khó
chịu một tí đó là khi ghi hai cái xe Lát
này hay nó sẽ lại ghi đè lên hàng này
Đây là cách tôi thấy ghi nó là ác select
như này
Ồ vậy à sẽ ghi thêm câu select cho nó
chứ tao không ghi đè lên nhau lại nó sẽ
kiểm nha à
ta có
Ừ cái nó đang bị đó là lép mình thiếu
lép roi thằng gà nó cho bị thiếu
tôi không rõ là có lép cho sắp nữa
hình ảnh trà có đầy đủ ngon à
à à
ở đó là ok chưa Đây đây là cách mà ông
xử lý khi mà khi một câu truy vấn Lý do
khác phức tạp nhất là nó liên quan đến
có cả những cái Hàn Thì đó thứ 2 là nó
liên quan đến do I would bye sau đó thì
ông Ghi trình bày nó sẽ như thế này đây
là chẳng qua tôi có kinh nghiệm rồi tôi
tôi làm này ngang với mấy ông của mỗi mò
cái này cho mẹ ông tốn thời gian hồi đấy
đâu không thôi mà tôi làm lây 2 năm liền
ở chỗ không Không tôi không tìm hiểu sâu
về đây là quần đâu mẹ tôi không biết
được những cái hàm để mà làm nhanh làm
giải quyết nhanh được như này trông béo
không không phải tôi thấy cái vấn đề tôi
giải xử lý nhanh được tính thế mày ông
thậm chí á Thế là câu truy vấn này tôi
còn chẳng biết được làm sao thôi đấy rồi
đấy Tôi không biết làm những cái chi vấn
khó đâu đấy nhưng mà cái này ở tôi đang
hướng dẫn là mấy ông đến với ông
Ê mấy ông đi qua thì càng tốt không nhìn
về em cũng nói là mấy ông về sau nhớ đại
khái mang án gì gì đó hoặc có tôi đây mà
tôi vẫn sẽ bảo hành trọn đời trong bé
ông không thắc mắc gì thì có thể hỏi ông
ạ Bây giờ tạm xóa Này nhá Nhưng mà tôi
vẫn sẽ để lại Cốc ở đây mấy ông thích
thì tham khảo nhé tôi xóa 23 này trái
nghĩa gì đấy Ok nhá á
từ ngày 20 triệu mình có câu fk có hư
cho mình xử lý do như thế nào vẫn Tôi
thấy hay
Mày chưa làm cái gì cả 9 giờ tôi cảm
thấy là cái
Ừ cái À à
Em không biết làm cái này tôi nghĩa là
vẫn kịp trước tháng 10 để mày ông có thể
đăng CP lên đây xong rồi sống gọi các
bạn Nói chung là tìm kiếm các công việc
làm cho mấy ông đấy nhưng mà để mà tôi
dạy cả về Trang về
anh chàng về chương trình đào tạo có thể
thấy trang quản lý trường ấy chắc phải
để thời gian sau 6 tháng 10 thử Tôi
không nghĩ là kiêng được hết bây giờ Tôi
bảo tháng 10 có rất nhiều với thứ quan
trọng đối với tôi mà
cho tôi sẽ bắt đầu đi dạy buổi tối ở bên
FPT
sẽ có ít thời gian để livestream như này
hơn
em 20 tuổi chưa là cái gì cả nhưng mà
Đúng là nếu mà 25 tuổi mà cũng chưa từng
có cảm xúc với ai Thì đấy là do không
còn nếu mà 20 tưởng từng có ông có cảm
xúc người khác rồi mà người khác không
có cảm xúc với ông ấy Thì đấy vẫn là do
hiểu về đúng không phải xem xét lại tại
sao mình ở như thế à
Ừ nhưng mà quan trọng gì mọi người đâm
đầu và yêu không nghĩ mình phải đâm đầu
mới yêu không ạ Nhưng nếu là sự ông thực
sự ông muốn yêu thật thì à Ông cảm thấy
là mình xứng đáng để được yêu chưa mình
xứng đáng phù hợp với con người như là
Vân tôi không có tâm nói về sự nghiệp
nhiều đó nhá Bởi vì nhiều người thì giàu
sẵn rồi dao chỉ thiếu mỗi kỹ năng tán
gái trở thành ra cái nữa thì sao lại
không nói nhiều vấn đây đấy
Ừ ok à bây giờ quay lại cái á
quay lại mình hôm trước mình làm biếng
quá rồi đây mình cần hiển thị toàn bộ
thông tin ở đây mình chị ra không ạ thì
à Bây giờ mình sẽ lại dùng api để mà
kiểu hiển thị ra ông ạ sau đó thì mình
làm à thêm mới thì sẽ như thế nào Thế mở
rồi đang thấy bài toán thêm mới nó khá
phức tạp khi mà chưa có công ty nào cả
thì mình sẽ phải nhập nó khá lắm nha
ngoại
rồi tôi tí nhá Đợi tôi một tí
thì đầu tiên mình cứ mở cái router trước
lên để xem nữa nhá
a router hôm trước là router
mình tôi định tầm quan trọng api nhoi
nghĩa là mình cần gọi đến cái cái này nó
sẽ trả về toàn bộ vậy đăng bài đăng kí
hộ xuân trang để mình sẽ chỉ ra đây đó
ông ạ ạ ạ
ở bên hôm trước lại bị phuộc will này
amin này hốt này in bed này thì mình có
ẩn cái đoạn A Khắc để mà lấy dữ liệu rồi
không ạ ai các bạn lấy dữ liệu đây thích
cái ông mà enter anto cách là gì đấy là
kiểu do data ngay
cái để cho nó sẽ in dung là cái xác này
để làm gì cho nặng thế à
nhà mình cần truyền lên thứ ra làm bản
chất là mình về sau mình sẽ phải truyền
lên cái phân tranh ấy là trạng mình đang
ở trong bao nhiêu Tạm thời thì bây giờ
mình cấp bạn để chống ngã
mình sẽ có là sắp xít và phê không ạ Sắp
sinh Alo ngay copy vào nha
công cho ca Mỹ chẳng có xử lý gì cả Mình
Thủy II nó là thôi đầu tiên là mình cứ
thử con salat xem à
thì mình lấy được nó về không Đã không ạ
anh ở đây tại Lạch Tray
I speak này
hai iPhone Ái Quốc của tôi này này bóc
này tôi để gửi đi
Ờ Ờ
nó đang không nói gì à
xin lỗi gì mà Tại sao xem
chết
mình lấy ngày đầu khi mở lâu nó cứ bị
treo gì đói em có đi bắt nó lại là được
ở lại nhanh hơn đấy
em có lấy toàn bộ bài đăng này lấy về
này
I spend The Way I
want tell về toàn bộ này thì ở đây ông
thấy có khái niệm là Data là những thứ
mấy ông muốn này cũng sẽ cần ta của ông
ông sẽ cứ chạy vòng lặp để ông in lần
lượt vào trong này nó xong ông đốt đầy
nó xong nãy ta đây nó trả về vị hơi bị
nhiều thông tin quá Thực ra là cái sao
ông sẽ phải cân nhắc ông phải xe lách
những cái gì mà mình muốn thôi không
phải lấy hết trả về như thế này ở đây
Tôi đang trả vậy Nó bị nhiều thông tin
quá đây chả thằng về luôn mình không sẽ
lấy màu gì cả mọi
thì
mình sẽ hãy salad rồi mình sẽ phải ạ ở
chung nhà làm sao cho phải sửa lại cái
quần xi sari là một một cái gì chẳng hạn
thế mà tôi sẽ sửa lại cái dữ liệu nó sẽ
của ta đây này bằng cái như thế này sau
đó thì à
Anh ở mình sẽ mình sẽ sửa lại dữ liệu
thì sao
anh
tí nhé Đợi tao một tí
bộ phim sẽ còn select ở đây
trực tiếp vào cái thằng cái hộp cùng
shisha với này mình một lần mình tạo
thêm gác trên bưu nữa
là mình à
Ừ nhưng mà tạo ACB thì bị sẵn Open nó
phải chèn thêm thêm nó mỗi lần mà
Khi mà mình sẽ xử lý các bạn anh như thế
này
qua lại vụ ACB nhé Nó là mu Tây tôi nha
nhỉ
trên Facebook
nghĩa là mình hoàn toàn thể sửa cái này
là
rồi hãy vừa nãy đâu vậy
ở
quần xi sari đúng không Mình sẽ
ở biển sửa đây quân sicily này mình sẽ
có
mình sẽ tạo cái file năm
sinh cái gì đó này
À mix
ờ ờ post
golsea
solari J5
máy XANH nào rồi
ở hiệu sách
à à thiếu tiêu phương thức nằm đây nè
Ừ ok
Ê mày hết cố tình sai chính tả đấy à
Ừ nó là mình sẽ có đây đúng không Mình
sẽ lắp lắp nick
constant đó mình sẽ quý gốc ở đây thôi
mình sẽ nước là web đây à
đó thì USD ở
Ừ nhưng mà như này thấy hình như này
phải sai sai nếu mà thằng này nó
và một cho nó chuyên vào đây không biết
được là thằng kia nó sẽ in any Nếu tôi
có thể thử thử đã nghỉ không được thì
thôi
thì alo mình phải biết ơn anh đã
mở cửa tạm bỏ lại đi
ừ ừ
xin lỗi rồi
lại
hồ
sơ thủ công bay về
cái này về bay mất cốt Ông nói cốt ở đây
Ê mày có
ở Sorry
Syria mua luôn 2 tác dụng gì nó chị đổi
từ
theo kiểu loa như này thôi hai người sẽ
tác dụng gì đây cả lửa
Ừ nhưng mà Đúng rồi cái kỹ 57 mới chỗ mẹ
hay nhưng mà có vẻ là không tác dụng
trong trường hợp các này lắm tôi cần ở
đây là cầm khi mà lấy ra thì mình cần
ghi đè lên cái thằng cũ
Price ở
thường sẽ làm nhanh nhé đó là ông sẽ vẫn
là mu Tito đây nhá một cái tô này
Ừ ông xã em ghét tạo thêm một cái két
CPU ngày vào đây uống sữa lại là Cu Lì
xi a
Sorry đúng không ạ
sự cố trang hạn đại khái như sau
đó thì
Ừ cái này nó
Ừ vậy thì đại địa Tĩnh
anh nha Cái này mà cuống cơ anh bằng ở
à à
chị sẽ cần bấm yes hàng
à hài mình sẽ ghét
xe Vespa ghét keys for you mình sẽ là
for rural
xem nhé
ở phòng và lưu sẽ tạo ra được i5 này a
funky này ừ ừ
em mãi luôn này hình như là mạng gì vậy
thử xem
Để để thử nhé mình nha ở tên về
dualit mua đồ First
Ừ để thằng đầu tiên này sau đó thì à
Ừ anh sẽ gọi đến cái à
cái này đi
có IQ này đi
ờ ờ Hà Nội
anh xóa bạn tại xóa Asus
ừ ừ
[âm nhạc]
khi trở về cái gì cả
trò chơi giá xóa rồi ở ngay đi em ạ
danh hơi sai
ý nghĩa ở đây phải vui tơ này phải tôi
lại bị nhầm đấy xét đúng nhỉ
Ừ tôi lâu không gặp lại có hơi nào một
tí ghét à đây Ghét Đúng rồi vẫn là ghế
ngồi xe rồi ghét này vì tôn Ngồi vẫn vì
Tôn
à à
Xin chào mềm cái gì đó
Sorry
luslec code IP website Hà Nội như vừa
nãy xóa ta sẽ appear thành là nó không
nhận
nó như này
anh phải làm lại
ở đó ra không không là như sai sai đấy
xe mà ghét Key
Ừ khi nào về không đúng lắm
Anh bảo lưu là trong bỏ qua không Thế à
a Mickey đây mới đúng
gian nữa
- 3
Ừ ừ
Em à hãy nhớ thằng này nó là chuỗi còn
thằng
mã số để đổi nó thành chuỗi thôi
Nhưng mà cái này mấy ông thấy là rõ ràng
mình có ra được cái review như này đúng
không tả lại cha không xem thì nó không
hể khi mà ông bikini ra hoa của ông ghét
ra lấy dữ liệu trả về thôi như thế này
nó sẽ không gọi được vẽ chibi của mấy
ông để cho mày ông có thể lấy thêm được
Việt Nam đồng ở trong trường hợp này
đúng theo em thì có đâu thế Làm nào để
mà mình tự động thêm cái ntpu này khi mà
mình ghét một cái gì đó ra một là ông sẽ
phải làm ông Ờ ông Huệ app thêm cái
Annabelle append to view ông cha ta Test
IQ à
a a real như thế này
số 1 là ông tự động luôn luôn thêm tôi
không thích được việc đó tự động luôn
luôn thêm nó không hay lắm kiểu ông luôn
luôn thêm cái cái ahbu này thì mọi lúc
ông ghét ra ông vẫn thêm cái đấy nó
không thích không thích kể Open này lắm
thì tôi sẽ áp dụng cái ác append cầu
dạng thủ công nghĩa là lúc nào ông bốn
thì ông lấy thêm ra cái ông thể gọi tên
trai như này hơn là ông lưu về ấp em
luôn luôn lấy thêm ở trong trong này đây
tôi sẽ thử nói cả hai trường hợp nhé mua
nợ ông thêm cái Apple phẳng đúng không
giống như thằng ông ấy đã hướng dẫn này
Này ông sẽ chỉ cần là ông thêm fn đây
a a pen a special relationship
từ đài ông xã Open thêm kể ạ Luôn Open
thêm cái thằng này thôi nhé thế nào
chúng ta lại trang này
mô tả là nó sẽ luôn đấy thêm được dữ
liệu cho ông cái côn Sea Coast luôn luôn
được cái kèm giông kéo ai nhưng mà Thiệt
cả trong nhiều trường hợp có không cần
có thêm cổ này nó vẫn thêm như tôi không
thích kể trường hợp này lắm mà trường
hợp ở đây bản chất là ông pacnet như này
xong rồi này tao toàn này à
anh không biết nếu cái này xong rồi Ông
thấy Open thêm vào nhưng với điều kiện ở
với Tâm
hình ảnh béo thế Ở đây có khái niệm ở
với từng hạt ông sẽ Open thêm vào như
thế này nó hơi bị mất công một tí nhưng
mà ở về cơ bản thì nó vẫn thằng level nó
vẫn sẽ tự động làm cái vụ đấy cho ông
khi mẫu pen kiểu nghe nhá nó vẫn tự động
làm hộ ông cái đoạn này Đây nè tôi nghĩa
là cả 2 cái đều như nhau rồi
đâu lâu
ông sẽ Open thủ công như này thôi nghĩa
cách này nó hợp với nhiều người hôn kiểu
bởi vì rất nhiều lúc và ông không muốn
tự động Open ngay lắm hạn chế tự động
Open như này nhá trước khi ông Đúng là
trong mọi trận đấu không cần phải dùng
thì không phải làm như thế thôi
hình ảnh
loa data
Ừ cái này sẽ ra sao Thế là mình sẽ lấy
hết dữ liệu ra thôi mình sẽ Japan từng
hàng vào này
em xem lại thôi Kết quả nó như nhau
nhưng mà rõ ràng mà
chứ không phải trường hợp nào mình sẽ
thêm men vào đúng ạ
không muốn không muốn kiểu như thế ông
thấy ẩn đi mà nó không ông sẽ ẩn luôn cả
cái thằng à kia đi là hợp lý nhất tôi
thấy ẩn đi hợp lý nhất không thể sửa
thẳng cái thằng mà
thứ ngày
Ừ
ông hệ ghi đè lên kiểu nhà
để cho người khác không bao giờ biết
được là là ông
ông có cái thằng này là 122 thì cả nó sẽ
không đoán được ạ
thế này thấy cái này là hay nhất
ở đây
xã hội họ sẽ nghĩ là mình lưu cái này ở
lại mà song.ao bay đúng ạ những chú gà
không Cái chẳng hạn thế rất là hai này
cách làm của tôi sẽ như thế này tôi cũng
sẽ chỉ cho ông mấy ông rất nhiều trường
hợp với mấy ông thích áp dụng trường hợp
nào và ưu nhược của nó là gì Tôi hướng
đến với ông sẽ là như thế
hiểu thì thôi kệ nhé Từ từ sẽ hiểu nhỉ à
Ừ
Ok về mình có dữ liệu rồi em ạ Xóa dã
ngoại đi em mình có dữ liệu rồi
Eva
Ừ ok này mình có dữ liệu rồi bây mình
cần đổ dữ liệu vào trong cái bảng table
đồng mạng thì
cái gì nó phải sẽ bây giờ Xóa đầy đủ
nhưng mà sẽ kiểu mà mình cũng sẽ phải
cậu xử lý rất nhiều bài toán giống như
rồi đấy ví dụ Giả sử làm việc với api
mới là rất là nhiều nghe tôi phải về có
phải nó kỹ hộ api trả về như thế nào hay
là người nào hãy cẩn thận tôi chuyên về
bác em hơn là quan em à Nghệ An mấy cái
đoạn với bác em mới uống thể hỏi tôi về
có truy vấn này cũng nên xử lý Nói như
nào vòng lặp như thế nào tôi có thể
không chuyên về thuật toán nó lắm để xử
lý bài toán cho toàn không nhưng tôi
chuyên về sự phần tương đối để tôi sẽ hỗ
trợ được mấy ông ra ngoài ít nhất ở đấy
đâu mày không lên Sino tương đương tôi
tôi tôi làm được đấy còn để mà Mấy ông
giỏi hơn tôi chứ làm sao mà tôi thể làm
mấy ông to con tôi được không ạ
à Bây giờ mình cần là với mỗi dữ liệu
thằng này thì mình cần mà nhà mình cần
cẩu méo hình dung ở đây mình dễ cần ạ ạ
thêm một cái hàng mới thêm một cái dâu
mới hoặc thêm một cái tr mới gần như thế
đủ TD và đúng ạ thì thằng really như tôi
nhớ là có có cái thằng mà
bản thân Seri có sẵn rồi rồi Thấy bổ nha
Sáng
số 1 là ông kéo in kiểu HTML thuần hay
là có a pen tool này của em sử dụng có
rất nhiều bài này
khi isil Grow sữa rau của tôi sử dụng
được để xem nhé sẽ trở về Hay nhỉ Đấy
aventon cả ngày
nó hơi bị không hay ở lắm
xe Open tour
vẫn dùng trtd dạo này tôi không thích
định sẽ
bộ phim xe tải dùng như thế nào ở thì
đợi tiếp
trùm TD kiểu nông dân kiểu như tôi đã
từng dùng đâu có một cách rất hay để làm
được này à
cái hàng cho nó dễ tường minh
định chỉ cho mấy ông cùng cách khác đó
là
nộp khái niệm grab những kiểu mình sẽ
grab dữ liệu
à Cậu gói dữ liệu vào trong một cái thẻ
nó đó thì tôi nghĩ thằng Đây Rồi tới đây
có ai kiểu thay vì ông gạo Duy Tân cho
500 lít kiểu ngay thì ông chuẩn grab nó
nằm trong ví dụ nha Nhưng tôi thấy ông
này làm này về ổn nữa
ở
ngã đây mình sẽ có cái bản mình đây đúng
không
bộ phim sẽ có thấy bồ đây đúng không
thấy một đôi ta đây không dứt trong này
đúng không xong rồi cứ Thêm bây giờ mình
sẽ bản chất là vừa nãy tôi bảo là cái
thằng à
vì thế hãy trả về này đã trả về này mình
sẽ có cái ATB là data mình sẽ gọi lên
hàng ACB cho ta three stones
store nhé
anh trầm data này xong mình sẽ có ha mà
hàm fork
thế này
bộ X là khối của ra tiếp thuần và cũng
sẽ phá Giống cái thằng à phối của pp sẽ
khác Khánh thì hôi hay nó sẽ có là Index
này và lưu và thượng lưu này
từ ngày tổ chức sẽ thử con Sherlock cho
mấy ông xem qua đây nhá
à à
ở Mỹ Jack và value cho bé ông xe mày
à à bộ phận này giả làm gì ạ
hỗ trợ giảng
à à
Ông nói ông sẽ thấy da
ta0 Cái này không phải đấy cái thằng này
là Tùng giá trị một thằng này sẽ là ít
Tùng đã chị 15 chuẩn hơn và lưu đây mấy
anh đấy đấy đấy
Ok cứ thế thì bản chất ở đây mình sẽ cần
làm được gì ra mình không cần lấy bạn
xinh tái ở đây lắm
Ừ mình đây sẽ cần lạ đầy giá trị vào
trong thang bảng kia
xe đẩy giá trị vào mà đây từng hàng một
thì mình sẽ là
có ai đi à
Ê thằng thứ hai
thì mình sẽ là nếu để cho mấy ông cậu đỡ
phải kéo lên kéo xuống cái tôi thường Ai
có à
speedwell như này
Ừ
đúng nhỉ
tin nữa à
Ừ chắc để mở đấy nó béo sẽ thấy chia 2
phim ngay cho mày không tiện nhé
có một cái gốc Thái hồ đúng không ạ
ăn
cà na ích chấm
À mà thôi tôi sẽ sử dụng cái bên này đi
để cho mấy ông đang ngồi xem cốt ở bên
này nó tim Ờ Ờ
cái này cũng có
có Live View của Như đấy đâu nhé
ở đó là điều này
à à chưa phải đây vậy speedlite đời đấy
Ừ ông hoàn toàn mạng kéo lên trên như
này cái Xem cốt dừa nha cho tiện
à à
thế này ích tại à
anh ở đây đây cái remote Apple của mình
là à
Ừ thì mình ở đây mình sẽ Cần xử lý như
thế nào ạ
Ừ tôi sẽ muốn đánh dấu hiệu tích và là
có có thích hay không thích thì nó sẽ
remote thấy bồn đúng không
Mình có thể ra đây ra sức nếu mà nó đúng
thì mình sẽ cho lợi ích con không thì
mình sẽ bỏ qua rằng ạ
thì sẽ
anh không không phải
đúng à con mình cứ ghi không hẳn là tắt
lắm thì nó sẽ ngay thôi ngược ra Kích có
kiểu gì ấy
300 đoạn này sẽ không đi tắt gì đâu bạn
hãy sẽ cho nhanh
không ông ghi chỗ ngược ngay Sao ông sẽ
hoặc nhai hoặc như này tớ là sao là một
là cái này À cái này sai thì bỏ bỏ qua
này không Không in gì nữa
à Còn nếu mà đúng cái này sẽ trả luôn
đúng rồi đúng không Ngay sau đó đúng
nhưng sẽ in a x thì phải nhớ thấy
Ừ thôi đi kiểu này cho nó cho từng Minh
em mấy ông mới mà ông không Đỡ không
hiểu lắm
Ê mấy ông đôi khi ở đường có cốt phức
tạp hóa không người sau người ta chẳng
hiểu gì đâu nhé
It's pin này cũng thế này thủ tướng sẽ
bắt chước nhà thôi
à à
ngày Quen đóng dấu rồi
bộ phim heo A là
Nghe
danh Suri anh mang Sorry bản chất là
mình sẽ in ra ở đây có tận hả
A maxillary và ninjari đúng không
a
location nữa nhỉ chiếu location đôi khi
sinh ở đây Mày không cần à Tôi đang cần
City này với ạ đi chút vì xử lý chết
trước chứ
nối với cái á á
chỉ cách nhau bởi như thế này chẳng hạn
thế chả thế
Sau đó mình sẽ nối với
city nha à
à à
a tiếp theo nữa đó là
thì mình sẽ có là
I am in series
ăn xong đi nối với cái massage à
có dấu à
ở nhà đi à
nằm ở application bỏ qua này Status sau
Tết là hai ừ đúng rồi này thấy mình phải
ghi căn thiệp Mình có ghi đè lên các sao
tốt này nữa à
bị sẽ kỳ can thiệp cái status này đã xa
tất nên tôi đặt tên nó sẽ tốt lên đi
ở xa tất lên em ạ
về bản chất là mình sẽ
thế
này cho xanh tốt da này thì phải make
make thằng này đã
a
post status Nam nè
ở đấy có có có rồi mình sẽ chỉ cần à
Ghét Ghi như này
ạ sau đó đây sẽ là cũng sẽ ghi đề cái
sát tốt cũ bằng cái chợ tốt nêm nó
khi con lợn con ở bên này thì mình sẽ
Ừ cái này mình sẽ kiểu chứ cần in ra cả
status là được
tên Đinh admin tân binh ở
x chấm Sau tất cả được Thử tí xem ở
trong nghèo nhé
có
gì không nhỉ status English in nó ra rồi
à à
trang từ cuối
22 cách với pp thì giống như cách của
bạn phúc kia cũng là một cách hoa mình
sẽ
em có lấy Cắt chuỗi sau đó thì cắt chuỗi
bởi dấu phẩy à Giàu cách nhầm sau đó đi
lấy cái
lấy cái thằng cuối cùng
à Còn đối thằng Lara có rất nhiều cái
hay dỗi là nó có cái khái niệm gọi là
Hair thế này sau đó đi ông đồng thời
chuỗi gồm mấy ông đúng không chỗ ông có
thể là với cách cửa bạn cái và bảo là
nằm ở cuối cùng thì thì mình sẽ à
athirat như thế này chẳng hạn kéo là cái
chuỗi lấy ở sau cái kích thước cuối cùng
của mình ký tự này sẽ tìm được cách em ạ
Đấy thì ông sẽ lấy được ông sẽ chuyền
chuỗi của ông ngồi trong này rồi Ở đây
dấu cách nếu không sẽ lấy được cái thằng
cuối cùng của dấu gạch đấy thằng hepl
thằng nào tiện lắm ngon lắm à thả hộ của
rất nhiều hàm để ông Mùi Ngò mới không
dùng sợ máu nghiện thôi
tiếp theo là mình có khuyết tật cái tất
này thức là tôi không thích làm ở bên
theo thời gian nó bị loạn lên ngoạn
à à
ăn ngay đấy
à Dạ con người con niềm tin
chú chó non
thì tại sao đây bị thiếu một cái vậy cho
Viettel location này
31 part time này đang Siri À đúng rồi
thiếu một cái đế Grand
cần cũng cá Devil chút nữa biệt danh ở
đây là mình lưu hôm nào tới bây giờ gì
nhỉ à
à à
em biết ạ
có thấy gì đâu
bị nhược điểm Tí Nếu mà giả sử cái luôn
nung là ai trong mà không hay lắm Có
phải ít theo đoạn này
Anh thường à thường là tôi sẽ không làm
cái kiểu lại ông tôi ghi thẳng đều và
như này đâu mà tôi sẽ làm có những cái
cần ở xử lý như này tôi sẽ thương đặt
tên biến nó ví dụ led dokyson sẽ bằng
cái gì đó Nhớ ai đó sẽ là ổn hơn là mấy
ông xử lý này sẽ location đây ạ ạ
ở đồng hồ sẵn bình tĩnh bình tĩnh bình
tĩnh cái tiếp theo là cho toàn bộ những
cái xử lý là lôgic cả như này một là ông
để biến ra ngoài nhìn nó tiện
remote Apple ngay Chẳng hạn
như này thì ông bên trong rồi ông sẽ cậu
đỡ phải
ông không nên xử lý ở bên trong này ông
chị inner ra thôi Hiểu vị hôn giống hình
dung không ạ
Ừ có gì đâu đúng không Lại không có lại
chưa Lên các bạn có cái đoạn này bạn nên
đặt tên theo trùng cái này nó rõ nhất
này chỗ đây là Zen series em ạ ạ
ở Arab copyright
không muốn nó là luôn luôn cạnh nhau như
thế thì mình sẽ bản chất là mình sẽ có
thể ở đây
Ừ bắt buộc ngày nay và ngày mai
Ê mày có thì mình sẽ in ra chẳng ạ đại
khái như thế
là hình như là ghi kiểu này
Ừ đúng nhỉ
số 1 quà của video bình thường đi Không
ngờ cách viết tắt bạn này lắm mấy ông
thông cảm nhé
Tâm Tự thế với thằng á ranch để quen này
à à
a min min mod này
ở đây là Min bà xã start
Ê status play ends and này
khi họ vào đây sẽ lên bếp nhất là trong
ngày tiếp theo status ok rồi này pin
được này
Em hãy tổng hẳn ra ngoài cho tướng Minh
đúng không Thì một ống format ở Bắc Yên
for smartphones thực tế thực tế thì tôi
khuyên là thực ra là lý tưởng nhất là
ông Đáng lẽ là đoạn này Ông phải ạ Không
phải lưu nó là timestamp lên hang xem
rồi Ok ok rồi thì sau đó thì trả về thăm
stem cho người dùng và người dùng muốn
in ra Kiểu gì người dùng pin thì nó vì
nhất đoạn mày mình không nên xử lý pho
mát ở bác em Tại sao ví dụ Giả sử ông
format theo kiểu thời gian của Việt Nam
nhưng mà rõ ràng là mình bảo Trang mình
sẽ hỗ trợ bên ngoài mà không ạ thì cái
format đấy người ta lại thằng say và
người ta phải mất công phải và trình
phải chỉnh từ cái format đã chỉ rồi nó
khó hơn rất nhiều Nếu mình không nên là
cái đoạn này thì ông nên xử lý ở ven
sông ạ thì mình sẽ là
nitrat chất bằng
các bạn này mình sẽ format lại mình à
mình tra mạng thôi
ra Swift đúng không ạ suýt có đầy hàm
format date
dù cho mát Tết này
rồi ông sẽ chỉnh lại theo ý của mày
không muốn thôi là được lại mình sẽ có
hàm nude tông truyền vào cái chuối của
mấy ông muốn đây cụ thể đây sẽ lợi ích
tại crash thật ấn nóng lạnh cái sau đó
thì ông muốn nha
Anh Muốn Nó xảy ra hình cái kiểu gì cũng
chẳng thế
ờ ờ
eli kiểu gì nhé
trò chuyện này thực ra tôi không thích
lắm
có thể tự Tôi thích kiểu mà nhìn làm
phức tạp đấy ạ
Ừ ông tạm một hãng hàng mới không không
không cần được tạo ra thế
à à
từ đài ông phải lại oke nhé
này nếu khi làm câu kì quá
cho mình muốn có cụ thể thêm những cái á
ờ ờ có phần trăm phần trăm Chắc là tham
khảo Cái trên gỗ ngoài này phần trăm our
phần trăm thì gì đó mình sẽ là đây là
chữ B là gì đấy B
anh trả lời rồi Chết mẹ ở đây à
khi sex
à à
Đó là một trước bê nó hơi say say quá
ở đây phải mắt đấy nhỉ Tại bên chị là
phần trăm
a a when i
phần trăm a
a minute
ngày nữa Nhưng cái này cho Đấy được rồi
à
ngày
à à
À mà quên thực tế nhưng mà ông muốn đi
dạo này thì ông sẽ phải ghi trong ngoặc
như thế này hiểu mới gọi được hả Ừ
a tulokho format ở đây được
à à
khách sạn nhé
anh
như Dead
I walk five Fox YouTube
buộc phải làm với cậu cái một cách dị
khác
là gì nhỉ Có nhiều hàng giữa
để trình này
ờ ờ
hiểu Tôi không muốn
khi dùng thư viện rồi đấy Muốn là đơn
giản thôi chúng mày ông hoàn toàn thể
làm thư viện các thử thứ
à à
một mình nè
ba là nhiều cách để làm
ở những dùng di động nhỉ Em hãy cho J
nhỉ
bí thư viện
anh
phong trào làm thủ công người béo ngoại
cho cấp cái trục công đây
nude này sau đó thì Converse da chết vậy
ca nhạc không thì nên là ra kích nó nó
làm tốt lắm tạp vấn đề ngoài bạn kiện ở
đúng đấy
the best làm khó khăn thật nhiều ạ
I read News nay mình sẽ là
anh ở đây chị được
nitrat topic này sẽ là xe đi Đấy người
ta toàn phải có viết tắt của đoạn này
nhìn trông không hay lắm đúng không em
bị lừa đấy ạ
tự nhận khuyết ở trong ngày nghe xong
À mà cái gì cực người ông để kỹ à là
riêng lấy tháng phải cộng một với vì đối
với thời gian Speed lấy tháng thì nó sẽ
là tháng 1 ở sẽ bắt đầu đến từ không
riêng mỗi tháng rồi tự nhiên không tì
nghe lời cái vụ cũng muộn rồi đấy trông
buồn cười
ở
nhà máy ông ấy đổi lại cái này đôi lại
thứ tự của nó sự ông sẽ cho ngày lên đầu
đúng ạ ngày lên đâu
ạ sau đó đi à tháng
tôi làm gì đó Sai sai vậy nay phải là
mày nói cái này cách mới đúng
đi ông không quan tâm mình dây không chỉ
mang theo số phút thôi
À mà thôi Cái này không đến nỗi phức tạp
như này cái này ông hoàn toàn thể ta
thêm một cái mới chỉ ở máy ông nữa nhá
thì mới ông tôi thường này tạo một cái
file 1 file gọi là thường ấy ở công ty
thưởng sẽ đọc file này thế là mini
I mean X phải mở cái gì đó Brooklyn lại
là tên kiệu Hòa file tên là helper được
chấm rét như này pha này sẽ là mình sẽ
tổng hợp những cái hàm giống ở bên
pp bị sự tổng hợp cái hàng mình sẽ khai
báo hàng ở đây là ví dụ hàm là Converse
à à dead to their Heart phải ngăn
chặn chuyên đế ở trong ai có bản chất là
mình sẽ làm đúng cái mà mình vừa làm như
này
ờ ờ
khi nghe xong
ở đây mình sẽ đổi cái đất này chuyển
trong
A và đây
ở nhà mình sẽ có led thất
đi bằng hai mày xong rồi mình sẽ chuyển
x chấm
a chất vào trong ngày à mày đứng yêu
mình sẽ phải khai báo số này ở chưa đủ
mà mình sẽ phải à ở nhà báo lỗi thì nó
kệ đi không Tao mình mình sẽ phải cậu
import cái Hà này bằng cách là mình sẽ
truyền vào trong cài lấy em thôi Đây của
tôi có cái đây không ạ chèn thêm file
trong này và nữa được này sẽ nằm ở tử
cung nó sẽ là hepl ngay ở nhà mày ông
phải cắt cho ship rồi là trung học lia
cách thức hữu thứ để mà đề phòng của
mình chưa yêu for import được file Zace
đấy ngoại
anh không được này sao được nghỉ à
ừ ừ
mình mình import cái thằng à kia vào
chưa
à à lầm lỗi tôi nói tôi này không phải ở
đây bên này cơ tội lỗi thôi
nhưng mà tôi chưa dùng thôi nhé tôi
không không biết tổng ở đây bao giờ chưa
chưa dùng luôn
à à
áo xanh tay à
ở đây thiếu trước đây
chủ đề có vấn đề rồi
chú ý
mà sp
à à Vừa rồi do một cá nhân tôi không em
ạ Vậy trước
Tik Tok
vì nó không thấy mày rồi đúng không
anh Tốn hơi nhiều thời gian mỗi cái được
Index trong sự
chết mẹ nó luôn à
kinh đại bắt cái này có luôn ai không à
Đang nghỉ
à à
giận em nhé luôn như này mình có thể là
sẽ phải Ngay từ bên A pp chính xác ngay
thực về bên pp là mình đã phải trả về nó
nun thì mình sẽ tiến hành chỗ trống rồi
300 nên chả 7 nung như thế này cho người
dùng mà còn nói chung và ẩn nó đi mình
sẽ ẩn những thằng nào mà không có đi
cũng là một cách rất nhiều cách nhưng mà
nói chung và hạn chế chưa cả với dữ liệu
kiểu này người dùng xử lý khó cho không
có thì mình ẩn đi ở ngay ở bác em chẳng
hạn thế mày không hình dung không Nó có
hai trường hợp xảy ra đây nhá một trường
hợp là ông vẫn sẽ phải luôn trả về đúng
cái format để nơi chúng sẽ dễ xử lý
nhưng mà nhiều lúc trường hợp với chống
kiểu như này thì người dùng sẽ khó chịu
nên là Cách thứ 2 đó là có cái giá trị
gì có vấn đề là new như thế này ông Ẩn
luôn ở bác em đi cái ông trị trả về
anh nói chung trả về ít thông tin thôi
cũng được nó sẽ nhanh hơn một tí về tốc
độ một tí rồi một tí với tốc độ
ở Ba Vì ông trả về dữ liệu ít hơn thì nó
nhanh hơn một tí nhưng mà ông ấy chạy
vòng lập để ông duyệt mà đây là nó không
hẳn là nhanh hơn nhiều lắm đâu chàng Hoà
cái người xung khi mà nhận về cái cái dữ
liệu ấy sẽ nhẹ hơn một tí
em hãy xóa bớt đi mà đấy
À hôm nay tốn hơi nhiều thời gian cho
cái vụ à Mỗi kẻ ATI này có khi hôm nay
vẫn chưa làm được cái sửa xóa đi có
nghĩa hôm nay chặn tạm thế này đã bây
giờ làm thêm không kịp thời gian làm một
cái gì đó thêm
ở nhà à môi Đừng quên quên làm thêm cái
nó cái Phương cha cho mấy ông nhé Thì ở
đây mình cần có cái dưới ở phân tranh
không ạ vất anh trên lại được thì khi là
mình thoát được xong dữ liệu thì ngoài
việc hiển thị ra toàn bộ như này thì
mình cần những kiểu inna cho mày một cái
kiểu Phương tranh hay gì đó đúng ạ thì
đợi tôi xem lại cái Phương Trang của
thằng à hyper rồi đã
Anh Hợp ơi lại có cái phân trang tôi sẽ
ốp cái phần trai của nó
Mấy ông tôi mới lâu rồi chứ tôi một cốt
bình thường một ngày cốt ông nhiều nhiều
thức
không không ngủ kiểu dạng làm chậm chậm
Nhưng ai đâu hay tiếng song mỗi một tính
năng thế quá chậm
Ừ nếu mà thử gỡ Không sao cả ông chậm
Nhưng chắc không Sao vậy ạ Không xử lý
được dứt điểm một cái bài toán là tốt
rồi nó không chê được như thế ông vì ông
kiểu bị kiểu ngựa non háu đá ở cậu cứ
phải trong trọng nhanh nhanh chóng sóng
chất như thế năng cũng gốc không không
cần như thế không em chậm Nhưng chắc
được
này cho nó đẹp nhá thì mới Ông thấy có
cái nó D đây đúng không Thì đây mình cần
đổ dữ liệu vào trong cái á nữa nữa cái
nữa vi này Ừ thì đây á mình có ul mình
có thể để cứu lời trước nhưng mà nó
trống ở ngay trên này chẳng hạn sử ở
trên cái hết đồ này mình à Hết đầu đi
bởi vì rõ ràng tôi kéo số 1 Kong
Ừ ông nào hôm sau sữa tôi cái đoạn xét ở
đây nhá Không hiểu sao lỗi thì này cái
đấy thì à
đó mất bao lâu trong nó rất nhiều cái
tùy có cái kiểu thường làm tát thường
đều đều đều ý tớ làm khá nhanh một ngày
xong 3 4 tap nhưng mà có nhiều cái thì
ngọn rất lâu rồi gọi nhớ nhưng mà nói
chung là gần đây chán với cái lỗi lặt
vặt điều dạng là hồi trước sai lỗi chính
tả cũng có
anh có không hẳn ở sẽ lỗi chính tả bể
IDM về hỗ trợ để đọc thôi chứ nào rồi
nhưng mà ý à Chỉ có ví dụ gọi anh cái
hàm kiểu có rất là hàm dị rồi thêm một
cái chữ đê thôi Ngạn nó đã là cửa hàng
khác rồi mình sẽ tốn thời gian đọc kỹ em
tại sao mình cốt là giống hệt ấy trả lại
thì không chạy gì đó Gọi cho mất thời
gian
em rửa Mất 12 buổi
Anh cũng ở đây thôi còn nói gì tính sau
hai lọ lem
khi đóng về này mình sẽ có một cái ở
đây một cái ID là cái cái nết cái này
Xuân thể ra hai lại sau đó thì mình sẽ
gọi mình mình sẽ đổ dữ liệu vào trong
này không ạ
có cái khuôn Tết này đánh đánh số này
trong mấy thằng kia ngày ông thấy đoạn
này dùng la rồi ạ lòng dùng
kiểu đã cho thấy bồ đúng nó đoạn này nó
sẽ tốt đúng không
được Asus nó không khác gì cả à à
Ừ để xem
anh
có một ông ở đó làm thế này rồi
ngồi cốt các bạn hãy thôi nó xem
ta làm rồi
khi con chuột
A Gọi hàng fake giận dữ liệu internet
render dữ liệu ở ở
bác em Ông ấy giữ ông ấy tạo dữ liệu của
bác em xuống đổ vào ạ đổ HTML vào ạ
Không không khẩu không ai làm thế này cả
Bộ Công an làm thế Cả
nào
anh không làm theo nhé
này chứ
gọi linh
cái lạnh ngoài
chị Linh
ở đó Jack table 007
à à
Cậu phân trang dùng á giác như thế nào
khuyên mấy ông thật ra về sau lên trả
với kiểu nhà chúng tương minh hơn ạ
Con sẽ là kiểu hay vì ông trị trả về là
kiểu bikini điều này cũng sẽ trả về cái
kiểu iPhone xong rồi như thế này à à
ô hay hơn nhiều đó là ông chạy về sắc
luôn trả về trạng thái này chả phải đa
ta Nó bảo gì này ta sẽ làm đó ta trong
này đấy
Anh
bảo đây sẽ là ghét à
khi gọi ghép nói gì nữa rồi data như này
trở lại còn cái này sẽ là cái chữ nết
của mấy ông
uống xem nhé
Ừ đợi tí đợi thị đăng ký có Hàn có bị
Trãi có hàm để lấy được hả ta nhớ nó là
cái gì thôi à
ai ngờ Guetta à à
atarax à
có một cục số
I need u
làm gì đấy nik Collection đỡ nhớ
à à
bộ phim sex
không được
Linh bây giờ không được Tại sao anh nha
Anh bình thường gọi Linh được mà
A Gọi Linh
không cần không
a Window in collections
ừ ừ
đúng chỗ này đi
ở trong vệ ổn đấy ạ
Ừ
dạo này sẽ restore về là thí sinh
I just don't
cho thuê nhà bà
ở bên A Vinamilk này mình sẽ in vào
trong cái thằng cái Vinasun này đúng cái
dữ liệu mà mình đang
Ấn Độ ra
anh giải thích tôi Nghĩa tổng trong cái
ha mà tốt nhất sẽ tạo là người Hàn nữa
anh ở đây hà mã hà mà
à à render
khi extract
cho Vinasun hay
Linh chẳng hạn cho mình sẽ chạy vòng lặp
có ý từ đây ở đây mẹ ạ
hai chân phối cả đây
bộ
xử lý
độ dữ liệu vào
ở đây à
em copy code mày nhá
để xem Cốt
phải thứ mình sẽ in ra đây à
Vì sao nói đi này
cách Xóa ID này
ở nhà Mày có classname ở đây link xong
sẽ đổ nó có trong cái hát HR đây Okay
này
em sẽ copy cái đoạn ở bên này nhanh thôi
ở đây mình sẽ có
a a pen
em copy đoạn này
a destination
A
lỗi này
anh nói gì này vào đây sẽ
anh em cái gì
events thế a này
ông ngoại phim sex Japan a
Ừ Thế lấy thì à à
a-class là cái này có cảm nghĩ độ thả
mỗi lúc tôi bắt đầu thấy làm đoạn này
hơi khó
cực khó lắm này gặp em sự thẳng cái này
xong
chị sẽ làm cái này đi thẳng thì lại đi
ờ ờ
đây mình sẽ có là
anh
em để lệch này
Anh xóa đi nhé
xe có
x.pro Al ở
A và
ở đôla x chấm
cái khái niệm là đang ấy Tít đây không ạ
Người ta là đăng ít thì mình sẽ làm như
thế nào nhưng sẽ cho nó thêm cái class
Active là được
a-class Active đang ở trang 3 làm ít
đúng không em thêm class hít vào đây này
mình đây sẽ là
ờ ờ ờ
ex2 ạ Ừ nó là Chu phone được
chống lại ở
Ừ Ok em lấy thì muốn gặp em ở đây nữa
tên
ở đôla đấy Kệ đi ở đó
ở đó tôi chỉ cần gọi Lấy cái Hàn Prado
này nhìn sẽ gọi đến Hàm Ronaldo này
truyền thông ạ
trò chuyện hàng ngày
Spore này
cho Vinasun này là xong sao đây
rồi đấy ngon giao diện trước đẹp không
Tại sao cho đẹp nhỉ Cái này à lời của
tôi chưa có cái chưa có class nào cả
có thể mẹ mày ông hình dung chị nào
mình chỉ cần có class thêm cho thằng
ngày mình sẽ
ở
trận ultraview classic
à à
a a
tribute là les là cái đoạn này ra xong
đã test link nhận định ok
tủ bếp ai tâm rồi mà
Ừ gì mà ừ
anh đi rồi
á nhon
tí nữa tôi có tạm Ẩn Hoài đi đã đúng
không Tôi đổ thẳng dữ liệu trai vào
trong cái này xem thực sự được là nó có
đúng là đẹp không đã
Anh đang đi dạo này có vấn đề gì đó
Ý anh hỏi đi này
Âm Nhạc
ừ ừ
này có cần thắng dưới đâu cần span đâu
nhỉ cái cái nết cái item
ăn Tết
ăn cơm đi đâu nhỉ lửa
nhà mình có khác yêu nhỉ
tệp
add ID echinacea này
không khác gì đúng không class cái tên
này
ăn tết Linh à
à à tên classname nhìn vậy sao đây thì
sai chỗ tôi lỗi tôi nói tôi Nội Tôi
em đứng nhà nước tránh khỏi lỗi các bạn
nữa thôi
ảnh
không thêm class à
The Flash
Ừ bắt bay nữa để trôi sang bên phải
a song
có bao nhiêu chúng ta đã có một trang
Index phân tranh giao thừa sĩ gió đông
Ừ nó
Ừ nhưng mà thế này vẫn chưa xong
thứ nhất à Trang 1 của tôi đang nói tiếp
mà nó ngon
em đi rồi sao
Anh đi vào trong như này mà
thì thôi vỡ trong đẹp ngay mà Ừ có thử
lại cốt nha
ở mức lửa
Ừ nó bảo cái này chính rồi đúng không
Mày không thấy rõ ràng đúng không lầm
lỗi tôi phân nữa Active phải làm đến nên
lưu ý
anh bình tĩnh Nếu có bị sản
à à
ok chưa nhưng bấm thời trang hay đúng
không Bây giờ xanh hai đúng không
ha ha
Khi
bữa ăn sáng hay thì bản chất là mình
không nên điều hướng sang cái thưởng như
vừa rồi đúng không Chị sẽ cần làm đây là
gì mình sẽ gọi đến cái thằng này
em có thực tế là tôi vẫn muốn 7 lên cái
pate bằng hai lên 2 địa chỉ cơ đấy để
đến tế bằng hai thôi chứ không phải
đường link như thế này lắm đừng Linh này
thì mình sẽ phải lấy đường link này bạn
chất ở đây mình sẽ phải có một cái on
click mình sẽ
xe đẩy sang trang mới trong mấy
Ừ thôi khỏi đợi khó làm lôgic minh kiểu
tư duy vẫn như thế Nó là kiểu như nào đó
là kiểu mình cần à
ở đoạn này mình Iraq mình sẽ đổ dữ liệu
vào này mà mình vẫn sẽ đẩy lên hai nhiệm
chi
ở một mình mà chúng điều hướng Thành địa
chỉ mình sang tháng 2
vi
phạm không tí đấy xem nhé
các em à bikini
bikinis mình bấm
anh ở đây mình sẽ ra bắt sự kiện đi nó
sự kiện là
nghĩa mà passionate mà thẻ mình được bấm
like đây
đầu tiên mình không Mình sẽ
mình sẽ ngăn sự kiện để chạy đặt event
defoe này sẽ ngăn không cho kích hoạt
sau đó thì mình sẽ à
mà để flanders ra hết tiền chứ không
phải là không phải là ở
á Vừa nãy tôi gọi Linh có được đâu
đây ở render HTML mấy ông hình dung
không anh trả về Linh đúng kiểu như này
đến người muốn làm gì được Linh đấy thì
làm đây là api để mà
ở đây là FBI để mà kiểu mình mình cho
người dùng tùy chỉnh sau người dùng chứ
không phải là không phải là mình render
hết HTML Nếu mà Raider HCl thì bản chất
với ai cũng không đúng nhá ông bắt Bộ
mày trả về dạng vi sinh trả về dữ liệu
Thôi nhé Xong rồi người dùng làm gì về
dữ liệu đấy việc người dùng nó mới chọn
anh ở đây là mình cần à Tắt cái này đây
mình cần là mình sẽ
thì mình chỉ cần lấy cái là cái tách ở
trong thằng này
dù là đang ở trang thứ bao nhiêu gần như
là thế
cho tôi thử trong đêm xem nhé nick biết
rằng
classic II
gì chấm tách
à Xong rồi con solo chấm rock
em hết mẹ được
anh cho em xem
Ừ ừ hôm nay hơn hai tiếng rồi mà ông mà
nghỉ trước cũng được không sao nó thắc
mắc thì cứ lại họ rồi
vẫn bị nhảy sang này
bấm vào ai mà
Em có phải là nó không bắt được với cái
này được mất sau thì thấy a được nó sau
đây là tôi lại phải chơi cái trò mà tôi
từng làm cho mấy ông xem đó là mình sẽ
phải đó của mình Mình sẽ bắt sự kiện đau
thương mình
khi mua chấm ngon
A lô g với sự kiện là
ở nick và
à Mà cái thằng đối tượng sẽ ra hàng ngày
chỗ này làm được này
em không có lửa đấy sao thế nhỉ xem à
chị Hà không gọi cho này được nhá Có
công minh on click đó cái mầm non của
tôi bị nhầm vẽ on
ở Việt Nam sao nhé
từ
ngày tôi thấy thằng này đang về không
nhận được
khi bạn bỏ h page của tôi ra một chỗ đã
nhá
Cho anh xin phép tạm bộ
bí ẩn đi Anh Thế ăn nó đỡ bị chuyển
hướng thì tôi xem là bắt được cái này đã
bắt bắt được cái thằng Sự kiện nào đã
đi này là HTML Download xong rồi nó khác
với ra với cái A sách này được lót xong
còn đều không Vứt cái này vào trong này
nhưng cái này vứt vào trong này nó vẫn
say bởi vì cái này nó đang Ronaldo cái
này nó ra quyết xử lý bất đồng bộ Cái
này đôi khi lendo calendo nó vẫn chậm
hơn cho thằng này sao anh không chơi cờ
đấy rồi
vì vậy Bấm mất thế đấy không được nó gọi
kiểu này nó gọi cậu này thì nó không
đúng lắm thì phải
Ừ nếu gọi cái này nói chuẩn mình gọi đến
thằng con mà
nhé
bị
nó hơi bị dài quá Tôi có enter xuống
dòng nữa đấy để ly rồi đến A ơi
dụng gì
Ok rồi Ok rồi không sao con không đi cho
nhìn nhé tường minh không Nào
tất cả hơi bị dài
ông gọi đến ht1 nó không đúng cô em Lờ
nó ra nhiều hơn
Đúng không Anh sẽ quên đâu
sẽ truyền lên hai địa chỉ Mình sẽ truyền
lên Giả sử đây ở trong trường hợp mà
không cần tìm kiếm gì đó anh sẽ nói
chung là mình sẽ đẩy lên Futsal URL
à à Tao làm Speed
cách chèn thêm một cái para là Tết bằng
mấy Bằng mấy em ấy trên da Speed được
em
chuyển lên đây này
ở chung kết lên đây này là được
đâu chấm location
Trần Hz mình sẽ điều hướng đến cái URL
Hazard hả
Em
thử nhé
tôi làm tại sao phải mất công làm lại
trong suốt ta thấy vì muốn là
Ừ đúng cái eol hiện tại sao
à à
AK tội lỗi tội lỗi rồi đấy nhưng mà ông
thể điều hướng không khi mở mại thử nhân
à Có sao chẳng hay ngon không nó sau đó
thì giờ mình sẽ cần làm đây làm gì mình
sẽ truyền thêm cái Tết ở trong mày là
xong hết băng lấy từ Thanh địa chỉ về
thì có thể là
một tác dụng kéo Lấy kiểu như này hay là
này
a z bà làm
I
wish I
anh ạ
[âm nhạc]
à thả dụng quét Tối nhanh hơn xin phép
dùng quét ngang quét trứng a hàm của TP
hiện ngay
I Guess Factory
tao đợi mày à
nãy để toàn bộ kiểu
em ạ Bây giờ là nếu không có thì mình sẽ
cho nó mặc định bằng một lúc đầu khi mà
không có vào như thế này thì nó sẽ và
trang đầu tiên
ngoạn cho tiên mình 42 Đúng nha nhiều 42
đấy mình inbox lỗi vài cái
ở đó ok chưa xong không toàn bộ đấy Ừ mẹ
mày ông đã làm quen được việc là làm hết
toàn bộ bằng giá Switch thì nó sẽ trông
như thế nào mặc ra Suite các thứ đoạn
này nó hơi bị mất công rồi vì ở mình
không thùng thư viện nào cả thì dùng D
thuần với ạ tự tự tạo hepl rồi ơi chung
là lằng nhằng khác nhưng mà tội cho xong
mấy ông cách xử lý các thứ thứ không ạ
mình phải chú thích ở đây nó lại mình
phải Trước hết là ai đã thích cái đoạn
này Tống sư cái á đoạn này cũng Tống sư
và cái hàm ở trong này cũng được Kêu
thấy
check in eight rồi các thứ thứ a e cứ
toàn bộ bằng nói chung là ngoài về việc
là xử lý mấy cái này đó là mấy ông đã
quen được việc khi mà tôi gặp một cái
vấn đề gì đó cách giải quyết đi Bắc của
tôi là như thế nào ấy vẫn là cái quan
trọng nhất không phải tôi dậy cho mày
ông cái này chọn điểm gì cả bởi vì mấy
ông mấy ông Đau về sau đâu có làm dự án
kiểu này đúng ạ về sau mấy ông không Cốt
phần da Speed cậu để ông thấy J giờ đang
bị dài có không số ra Speed mà con trai
hơn cả so với HCl và 0,02 sau chúng ta
không làm như thế này mà chúng ta sẽ
phải dùng để thư viện một cái phim Quốc
gia ship ngoài đó nhưng cách xử lý nó
vẫn giống như này thôi đúng không cái xử
lý do như này vẽ lại lâu à tôi họ bị
đuổi quá tốn hơn nhiều đấy chắc là để
hôm nào đó tôi sẽ ngồi vẽ lại các thứ
sau nhé sẽ ở lại vì hôm sau
không ạ
Ừ kiểu gì mấy ông chẳng phải xem lại xem
chúng hiểu lắm chuyện rồi Xem lại cho
hiện cho cái đoạn nào cần phải tập trung
đoạn nào còn là đi nữa nhé gọi bọn mày
tặng kết thúc đấy đã trai phết nhỉ
Xin chào bạn nhé